가격을 좀 비싸게 매입한 부분도 있는
거 같아요 이거 나가면 큰일 날 것
같다네 안녕하세 빌사남 있니다 어
제가 오늘은 강남 빌딩에 투자해서
실패한 사례를 여러분들한테 소개해
드리겠습니다 아마 강남 빌딩의 실패
사례는 아마 처음 찍는 거 같은데네
그래서이 사례 같은 경우에는 작년
말이나 올해 초에 어 빌딩 시장이
굉장히 안 좋았을 때 그렇게 좀
손해를 그런 사례라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그래서 사실 이게 주소를
오픈하는게 어려워요 또 혼날 수도
있기 때문에 어 제가 그냥 대략적인
위치나 뭐 느낌 정도만 어 좀
설명드리도록 하겠습니다 어 우선 제가
세 가지 사례를 준비했는데 어 첫
번째 사례를 좀 보면은
2022년도에 80억 원에 되게
신축하지 얼마 안 된 어 그런 깔끔한
건물을 80억 원에 매입해서
2023년 1월 달 어 어 빌딩 시장
제일 안 좋을 때 예 그때 72억
원에 매각을 했습니다네 단순
계산으로는 8억 정도 손해를 본 거
같은데 근데 취득세나 이런 거
감안하면 거의 한 10억 이상 어
손해를 본 그런 사례라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다 그리고이 건물 같은
경우에는 월 임대료가 무려
2,200만 원이 나왔어요 연면적이
한 140평 정도 되는데이 건물의
위치는 강남역에서 어 그렇게 멀지
않았던 그런 건물이고 기존에 이런
낡은 주택을 멸실한 다음에 어
신축해서 좀 이렇게 깔끔한 건물로
만들은 상태에서 그걸 이제 80억
원에 매입을 한 겁니다 그리고
매입하지 얼마 안 돼서 거의 10억
이상 손해를 보고 그렇게 매각한
사례라고 보시면 될 거 같고요네
그래서 이거 같은 경우 대출 비율이
좀 상당히 높았습니다네 상당히 높아서
아마 좀 금리 때문에 견디지 못하고
좀 이렇게 싸게 매각한 것으로 좀
보여지고 두 번째 사례 같은 경우에는
2020년도에 매입했어요 그래서 이때
2020년도는 빌딩 가격이 정말
폭등하던 시기입니다네 금리가 거의
이제 0%대 접어들면서 빌딩 거래량이
굉장히 좀 많았던 그런 식이고 그때
47억 원에 매입을 했었고 대출을 한
36억 정도 받았습니다 대출 비율이
좀 상당히 높았죠 근데 그때는 워낙
또 저리고 해가지고 대출을 좀 이렇게
무리 하게 좀 받았습니다 한 2년
정도
보유하다가 2022년 11월에
44억에 매각을 했습니다 그래서
47억 사는데 44억 매각을 했어요네
그래서 작년 한 11월까지만 해도
담보대출 금리가 거의 막 6% 뭐
7% 넘기도 했습니다 그리고 이제
그때 시장 자체의 분위기가 되게 공포
분위기였어요 이런 고금리가 뭐 2년
3년 뭐 그 이상 갈 수도 있다 이런
얘기들이 굉장히 많았거든요 대출도
많이 받은 부분도 있고 좀이 부분을
견디지 못해서 좀 이렇게 상 가격보다
더 싸게 매각한 것으로 좀 보여지는데
뭐 단순 계산으로 봤을 때 이때 그
전에 매입했는데 더 싸게 팔았으니까
그리고 취득세까지 하면 손해가 이것도
거의 한 10억 정도 될 거 같거든요
이렇게 손해를 보고 매각을 했고 근데
4 4억에 매입하던 분은 한 7개월
뒤에 무려 70억 원에 매각을
했습니다 그래서 거의 뭐 20억 이상
어 그런 시대 차익을 본 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다 사실
좀 아쉽긴 하죠 한 7개월 정도만
버텼으면 충분히 70억의 매각이
가능했는데 어 그걸 견디지 못하고 좀
빠르게 어 매각을 해 가지고 좀
손해를 본 어 그런 사례라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 역삼역 인근에 있는
어 건물인데 이것도 뭐 건물이 이미
있는 상태였어요네 그리고 이제
용적률도 이득본 건물이고 그래서
건물을 지금 당장 수익률이 그렇게
크진 않았지만 어 뭔가 조금 손을 본
다음에 뭐 리모델링을 한다면 어
수익성을 더 올릴 수 있는 그런
건물이었습니다 그래서 개인적으로 작년
말에 좀 되게 싸게 너무 싸게 매각을
한 거 같아요네 어찌됐든 그거 잘
캐치하고 사셨던 분은 어 7개월 만에
이런 좀 큰 시세 차익을 남겼고
그리고 마지막으로 2021년도에
170억 원에 매입을 했습니다이 건물
같은 경우에 근데이 건물도 신축한지
그렇게 오래되진 않았어요 170억
원에 매입할 때 대출을 무려 약 한
120억 정도 받았습니다 대출 좀
많이 받았죠 근데 사실 21년도
아지만 해도 금리가 매우 낮았어요
그때도 뭐 담보 대출 받으면 뭐
2%대 3%대 뭐이 정도 됐는데 이때
대출을 좀 많이 받았습니다 그리고
가지고 있다가 2023년 3월 달에
이때 161억 매각을 했습니다 그래서
요것도 취득세 감안하면 10억 이상
손해를 본 사례죠 여기도 여기
강남구청역 인근에 있던 건물이었고
건물 상태도 굉장히 좋았습니다네
그래서
요것도 좀 안타깝게 그렇게 좀 손해를
본 그런 사례라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 좀 정리를 해보겠습니다
그래서 어 세 가지 사례 를 좀
분석을 해보면 공통점이 일단은 대출을
좀 많이 받은 부분이 있고 그리고 두
번째로는 좀 신축된 건물을 좀 가격을
조금 더 높게 줘서 매입을 한 그런
사례들이 있었습니다 그래서이 사례를
통해서 말씀드리고 싶은 거는 어
대출을 받았을 때 내가 지금 현금
흐름이 제일 중요한 거 같아요이
빌딩으로 무조건 대출 이자를 커버하기
보다는 진짜 빌딩의 건물이 다 비었을
때도 내
현금흐름으로이자 감 가능한지 이런
것도 되게 중요하거든요 그래서 지금
같은 시기에는 더 대출받는데 되게 좀
주의하셔야 됩니다네 그래서 지금이
사례들 같은 경우에도 조금 내가
버텼으면 이게 뭐 손해를 보거나 그런
부분이 좀 없었을 수도 있는데 좀
아쉬운 부분이 있는 거 같습니다네
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다